ذات مرة ، ما كانت الحرب على وشك
الحدوث ، تم رسم الأنماط ، كان الجنود
في مكانهم على استعداد للقتال ، لكن
القوة الأعلى جعلتهم يوقفون شيئًا
غير متوقع ولذيذًا حساء الحليب الدافئ
تبدأ قصتنا هنا في الريف السويسري
في الزوجين آم ألبوس حيث لدينا
صُنع طبق حفظ السلام الخاص
منذ ما يقرب من خمسة قرون مضت ،
فقد قالت الأسطورة في الواقع إنها دعنا
نطلق النار ، إنه مؤرخ
لجامعة بازل وهو يعرف
حساء الحليب هذا جيدًا حتى أنه كتب
مقالات عنه ،
يعتبر ميلر سوبر علاجًا أنيقًا
للمستشفى في صراع
الوضع منذ 909 الأطلسي الهند هو
إيطالي للغاية ، فإن كاتوليكا على
الستايروفوم غالبًا ما تكون محنة على وجود شخص جديد تمامًا
بواسطة Rick Spartan 400 محور على
جانب التلألؤ
تم تحديد التماساته القوية باللغة الإيطالية أنا
وليس نظام King Koopa stuntin بعد
فترة من الوقت أصيب الجنود بالتعب و
جائعين لذلك وضعوا ما لديهم من طعام
معًا أحضر الكاثوليك الحليب
والبروتستانت الخبز  د قاموا معًا
بصنع حساء الحليب الأسطوري
[الموسيقى] ،
مما أوقف المعركة وتم تشكيل هدنة ،
أصبحت البدلة مبدعة جدًا لدرجة أنها تحتوي
على نصب تذكاري في ساحة المعركة وبعد ما يقرب من
500 عام لا يزال الحساء
يلعب دور صانع السلام من الغد
وهذا هو روبرت الذي  كان المطعم
يخدم الأشياء لسنوات عديدة ، والبشرية
هي إيزابيل له ، وعندما سارت الأمور على ما يرام ، سارت الأمور على ما
يرام وتوم توم
الضائع والمتر على الهواء مباشرة في مجالس دنكان لانديس وهو
ينقط في سوبر بنين وهو
يصنع الحساء بالطريقة الحديثة مع
الحليب والخبز بالطبع  ولكن أيضًا مع الزبدة
والبصل والكراث ومخزون الخضار
الكريمي وبعض صانعي الرغبات بالملح والفلفل ،
لا نحبهم نحن
كشركة ، هل أدركت أن القفزات يمكن أن تفعل ذلك
في المرة القادمة التي تشعر فيها بالضيق من شيء ما
مع جارك.  السويسريون
هل تحضرون الخبز وتجلب لهم
الحليب ويأخذون وعاء من الحساء معًا
[موسيقى]